>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington DC.
>> Jane McAuliffe: Good morning.
>> Good morning.
>> Jane McAuliffe:
I'm Jane McAuliffe.
I am the director of national
and international outreach
at the Library of Congress and
it's my pleasure and privilege
to welcome you to the Library of
Congress National Book Festival
and to one of its two
stages that we have devoted
to the art of fiction writing.
National and international outreach
is the division of the Library
of Congress that is responsible
for this wonderful event.
The division was created just a year
ago to enhance the library's efforts
to serve Congress, the
American people, and the world
and to foster partnerships
with other cultural
and academic institutions; both
in this country and abroad.
The Library of Congress is thrilled
to present this annual
event for the 16 time.
We certainly could not offer
the free celebration of books
and reading that this is without
the generosity of our donors.
The Library of Congress is your
nation's library and I welcome you
to visit us in person on Capitol
Hill or online at www.loc.gov.
Today we have an outstanding
line up of authors on this stage.
They are among our finest writers
and their subjects range
thematically from the intersection
of rural life and faith to science
fiction, from espionage and romance
to stories based on
real life events.
The theme of this year's festival
is journeys as represented
by the art on our festival poster.
Books take us on journeys, often
to places we would
otherwise never venture.
Fiction in particular challenges
us with new perspectives
and opens worlds to explore.
In addition to the author
presentations you will hear today,
please visit the expo
floor at the lower level
where you will find family friendly
activities, you'll find the Pavilion
of States, and you will find
the Library of Congress Pavilion
where you can learn more
about your national library.
Now it is my pleasure to introduce
our next speaker for the first time
to a National Book Festival stage.
Avid reader, children's librarian,
professor, deputy commissioner,
and then chief librarian of the
Chicago Public Library and CEO
of Baltimore's Enoch
Pratt Free Library.
Please welcome to the podium, a
woman who recently added a new title
to her resume, ladies and gentlemen
I present you the 14 Librarian
of Congress, Dr Carla Hayden.
[ Applause ]
>> Carla Hayden: Wow.
Thank you Jane.
Welcome to all of you
the 16 annual Library
of Congress National Book Festival
and my first official event.
Can you imagine what this
is like for a librarian?
[ Laughter ]
This is a marvelous, marvelous way
to start my tenure and the theme
of the festival this year
is journeys and I'm going
to be inviting everyone to journey
with me on Twitter as I discover
so many of the treasures
of the Library of Congress.
So we're starting, in fact
we've already started today.
Stephen King has already
retweeted [laughter].
So it's going to be something, but
this today it is a special pleasure
to be able to present the
Library of Congress' prize
for American fiction, which
recognizes the contributions
of an American literary author
whose body of work is distinguished
and the prize has been given to
such notables as Tony Morrison,
Phillip Roth, John Gresham,
and this year the Library
of Congress is presenting the award
to a person that many of you know
and who has touched
readers around the world.
The recipient of this year's
award is Miss Marilynne Robinson.
[ Applause ]
Because we are live on Facebook,
I am going to just give you just
a little bit about Miss Robinson
because she is the author of
books that have touched us
for over two decades and she
has been an award winner of,
and I'm looking at my, look at
these awards; the Pulitzer Prize,
the Penn, the Hemmingway
Award for First Fiction,
and then 24 years later for Gilead,
she received the National
Book Critics Circle Award
and the Los Angeles Times Prize.
She is what you would call the
epitome of an award winning author
and she was, in this instance,
roundly and unanimously nominated
for this prize by a jury made
up of Nobel Prize winners,
Man Booker Prize winners, prominent
literary critics, and former winners
of the prize, the ones
that I just mentioned.
And as acting Librarian of
Congress David Mow said at the time
with the depth and
resonance of her novels,
Marilynne Robinson
captures the American soul.
We are proud at the Library of
Congress to confer this prize on her
and her extraordinary work.
Please join me in celebrating
the winner of the 2016 Library
of Congress Prize for American
Fiction, Miss Marilynne Robinson.
[ Applause ]
>> Marie Arana: [Inaudible]
what a joy
and what a privilege
and an honor to be here.
I'm someone who has
been a devoted fan for,
since 1980, since your first novel.
I have followed your work as so
many of us in this audience have
and beyond this audience watching.
It's very rare, I think, that
we have an American author,
contemporary American author
who digs down and speaks to us
or doesn't really speak
to us, shows us and brings
out in us somehow things of
conscious and loneliness and faith
and love in the way that
Marilynne Robinson has.
I have to admit that I
am, at full disclosure,
an avid partisan, unabashed
partisan.
I was on the jury, I was fortunate
to be on the jury as the chair
of the Pulitzer committee that
gave Marilynne Robinson the prize
for Gilead, of which I'm very proud.
A wonderful, wonderful
resonant book.
Marilynne, I wanted to ask you, I
wanted to talk to you a little bit
about how it is, these unforgettable
characters that you, that you paint
for us, that you engrave really
very deeply in our souls.
These are characters
that come, obviously,
from not only from your imagination,
but also from a deep sense
of your spiritual self and perhaps
of the spirit of all
of us in a sense.
Can you tell us a little bit
about where these spring from.
John Ames, the extraordinary hero
of Gilead and who appears again
in Lila, and appears throughout
in the trilogy really of Gilead
and then Home and then
Lila, the most recent novel.
All of these characters, it's a
little bit Faulknerian in the sense
that we go back to Gilead in Iowa.
Tell us a little bit about
where they come from.
>> Marilynne Robinson: You know
I really don't know [laughter].
I know that's not a terribly useful
response, but it is interesting
from my point of view that I can't
write unless there is a character
in my mind.
I have to wait for them.
They're not ideas of mine.
Somehow, I mean, you know
somehow or other a voice somewhere
or a character and surprisingly
when I begin to have the conception
of the character I really know
quite a lot about her or him.
It's an uncanny experience really.
I assume that what I do is sort of
watch the world and glean traits,
mannerisms, and attitudes
and so on out of,
you know my encounters
with people in general.
Not because I intend to, but you
know things stay in your mind.
That's the best I can say actually.
>> Marie Arana: How did,
how was it that John Ames,
which is such a distinctive
voice, the pastor of the church,
one of the churches
because Bouton is a,
is that how you pronounce it Bouton?
>> Marilynne Robinson: Bouton.
Bouton.
>> Marie Arana: Bouton is fellow
reverend in another church,
but how is, how did you, how
did that voice come to you
because it's a very distinctive
voice and I think we can all sort
of hear it and summon
it, your readers.
>> Marilynne Robinson: Well
I've, it's kind of a long story.
I was in a hotel in Province Town.
I was going to spend Christmas with
my sons, neither of whom was married
at that time and so I had a
room for me and a suite for them
and an otherwise empty hotel,
on the tip of the Cape.
And it was very beautiful and
they were both delayed coming
and so I was there in
this solitary hotel
in this wonderful winter sunlight
streaming into the windows and so,
and I always have a notebook and
a pen with me; you never know
and [laughter] and this
voice, the first sentence
of Gilead is actually the first
thing that came to me in that voice
and I was surprised frankly because
having only written Housekeeping
at that point, I assumed
that I would always write
from a [inaudible]
woman's perspective.
And then here was this man
[laughter] talking with me
in effect, you know who had
read all the same books I had.
[ Laughter ]
And it was, I really
enjoyed writing that book.
It was easier than I think
any of my other books
because I actually positively
enjoyed spending time
with that voice.
>> Marie Arana: It's a marvelous
voice and I don't want to suggest
that there's anything
Manichean in your world view,
but there is a sense, you get a
sense in the book that there's,
there's, you know there's
the good soul
and then there's the troubled soul
or the difficult life and the,
and the good life, the introspective
studied spiritually thoughtful life
and then this sort of, the
person of abandon a little bit,
a little on the wild side.
There's that, it's
not black and white.
I don't want to suggest
that it's black and white,
but there's always a sense of a kind
of a struggle between the people
who have strayed, should we say,
and the people who are trying,
trying very hard to stay the course.
And actually you are someone who is,
you've got your doctorate actually
in English, I believe, but
someone who has studied theology
and religion for a very long
time and steeped herself in that.
Can you tell us a little bit
about that sense of your,
maybe even Biblical sense
of right and wrong and good
and bad and, and grace and evil.
>> Marilynne Robinson: Well I know
that you don't want to be Manichean,
but you are a little more
Manichean than I am [laugher].
I don't, I mean this may be related
in a way to the way that I think
about my characters is sort of given
to me rather than inventions
of mine.
I don't, you know even Biblically
speaking, you know there are lots
of people, you know like David, King
David and so on who err enormously
and nevertheless very important,
very highly valued people.
I don't think we can actually,
I mean I think that a life
like Jack's, shall we say, that,
that encounters a great deal of sort
of psychological discomfort
and all the rest
of whatever you want to call it.
I think if we absolutely
it's precious in a way
as esthetically satisfying
as a life like John Ames,
which basically, what should I say?
He does not expose himself
to a world of temptation
or [inaudible], what I mean.
He lives in this very aware and
even uncomfortably aware of living
within a very highly defined role
in history and all the rest of it.
I don't, I think that there are
very, very many ways for people
to be esthetically
interesting, shall we say and I'm,
my own particular theology suggests
very strongly that God is sensitive
to these esthetics
and, you know beyond
that I don't particularly judge.
>> Marie Arana: Well I
certainly get that sense.
Jack, of course, is the character
who really was present throughout
in a sense at least in, in, as
part of the whole constellation
of the trilogy, but he is
the son of reverend Bouton.
I get the feeling though
in Lila, for instance,
I mean here is someone
who one, isn't sure.
She's, she's very much
attracted to and even loves
and says she loves John
Ames, Reverend Ames and his,
what he represents and finds
him beautiful in so many ways.
We're not sure she's going
to stick with it somehow.
I mean you end the novel
wondering whether she actually
and she's landed sort of in
this wonderful spot for somebody
who has had as troubled life as
she has and yet there is that,
still that remaining
kind of wildness.
There's a deep goodness in
her too, so I understand
about what you're saying that we are
not all lack of [inaudible] at all,
but Lila, tell us a
little bit about her.
>> Marilynne Robinson: Well
you know I, there were things
that I knew about Lila from Gilead.
I mean she's, it's funny
she's sort of there
in my peripheral vision, you know?
But I mean it was consistent
with what I knew about her,
that she had to be outside
the kind of acculturation
that produced people
like John Ames, you know?
He has a whole vocabulary
to describe and to,
you know to explore things
that are important to him.
I wanted her to be in her own
way without any of that apparatus
of learnedness and
tradition and so on.
Be a good theologian as he is?
>> Marie Arana: And she is.
She is. She is the one who is
reading the Bible and telling
at least the reader in, in,
in the words of the book.
>> Marilynne Robinson: Yes, yes.
>> Marie Arana: Yeah and that's
wonderful, sort of I think,
device because she, she very much
a deeply spiritual person herself.
>> Marilynne Robinson: And
one thing I liked about making
that character is that, you know
when you really look at the Bible,
the orphans and the widows
and so on are really the text,
you know how well are
they cared for?
How much are they acknowledged
and so on and all the Kings and so
on just rise and fall depending on
their adequacy to this population
that would be like Lila, you know?
>> Marie Arana: So Lila,
for those of you who have,
you really must read this
book and the whole trilogy,
but Lila is someone who has had
a very difficult past and poverty
and very gritty sort of childhood
and young womanhood and she comes
to marry Reverend John Ames who is,
obviously deeply in love with her
and has lost his former family
and is deeply in love with her.
But there is, there is
another character in this novel
that I want you to talk about
because it is, it was very present
in my, as I read it, it is
the knife that Lila carries
and it is very much a part of
her identity, very much a part
of her relationship
with her adopted mother,
if we want to call
[inaudible] adopted mother,
but there's the knife, you know
and the knife is very present.
It's almost like that Chicavian
thing about the gun, you know --
[ Speaking Over One Another ]
>> Marilynne Robinson:
Except I broke the rule.
>> Marie Arana: You broke the rule?
[ Laughter ]
The knife is never used.
>> Marilynne Robinson:
The knife [laughter],
to pare apples it is used.
>> Marie Arana: Yes to
pare apples it is used.
>> Marilynne Robinson: You know
that's funny because that's
such a byword that the workshop,
you know the checkout saying
if there's a gun on the mantel,
it has to be fired before
the end of the story.
So --
[ Laughter ]
A little act of rebellion
on my part perhaps.
>> Marie Arana: Right.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah there's a knife packed
right here and it's never used.
It's very, very present.
You're very aware of
it and you're weary
that it's going to be used or --
>> Marilynne Robinson:
It's her inheritance.
>> Marie Arana: It's
her inheritance.
It's everything she has, yeah, yeah.
>> Marilynne Robinson:
It's quite wonderful.
>> Marie Arana: Now I have to say
Marilynne you were born in Idaho.
Your father, if I remember
correctly, was in timber.
>> Marilynne Robinson:
Lumber, we lumber.
>> Marie Arana: Lumber.
[ Laughter ]
And your mother worked at home.
>> Marilynne Robinson: Yes
she was a classic housewife
of the period, yes.
>> Marie Arana: And you grew up in,
it seems to me I've never been
there, but in that beautiful sort
of lake area which is, which
is beautiful and full of nature
and inspirational in that sense.
Your writing is full of nature
and it's very important
to you, I believe.
Could you tell us a
little bit about that?
>> Marilynne Robinson: Well
I think that probably growing
up where I did where, you know the
length of wild landscapes seemed
so authoritative and enormous and
the human landscape seemed so minor
and perhaps temporary, you know?
I never stopped being
aware, you know?
I mean it's like an engrained
habit of, you know everything,
I mean trees, you know
I mean what can I say?
Nature is extraordinary,
very beautiful, very complex,
in exhaustible in terms of
the attention you can give it,
the interactions of
light with leaves
and all the rest of it, you know?
So it's on my mind, it is --
>> Marie Arana: It
feeds you in a way.
>> Marilynne Robinson:
Yeah, well it just, it has,
it assumes a lot of
authority for me.
I think that people live on natural
landscape events more consequential
for them than they
perhaps are actively aware.
>> Marie Arana: There's a, there's
a quote that I want to read to you.
You've got, was in the New York
Times and here it is talking really
about Home, which was the
second novel in the trilogy
and it is a book on sparring
and its acknowledgement of sin
and unstinting its belief
in the possibility of grace.
It is at once hard and forgiving,
bitter and joyful,
fanatical and serene.
It is a wild, eccentric, radical
work of literature that grows
out of the broadest, most fertile,
most familiar native
literary tradition.
I think what, I believe that
was A L Scott who wrote that
and I believe what was being,
there's a sense of you as a sort
of theological scholar and you as a
novelist and you wear these two hats
and you, of course you're
also a professor of literature
at the Iowa Writer's Workshop.
Very famous workshop as
produced, you have produced a lot
of wonderful students I must
say, but you wear these hats.
So there's the theology
hat and there's the,
there's the novelist hat and
there is the teacher hat.
These are all very different.
I happen to know a little
bit, something about this
because you really have to take off
one hat to wear the other one fully
and yet, you know here I am with
my Manichean view again [laughter],
trying not to be, but, and
yet are they all merge
in a way in your life?
I think you, the theology,
the spiritualism, the,
the notion of the importance
of faith and you are a Deacon
in your church I believe --
>> Marilynne Robinson: Actually
I was voted off the board.
>> Marie Arana: You were --
[ Laughter ]
We want to talk about that.
>> Marilynne Robinson: My
attendance was too bad.
[ Laughter ]
>> Marie Arana: Well you see,
so the good and the bad do mix.
[ Laughter ]
After all.
But so, the business of, on one
hand being somebody who is steeped
in imagination and is pulling
things really out of the air
because that's what a
novelist does, it hears voices.
A novelist is a person who hears
voices, pulls things out of the air,
creates a world, and a theologian
in my mind is someone who struggles
with the world that is
and where one hits in it.
And then the professor is one who is
trying to lead, you know in a manner
of a pastor trying to lead
a sheep to some sort of form
of understanding themselves, really.
So how do you do this?
How do you wear the hats and how
do you, if you see them as hats
or do you see them as all one thing?
>> Marilynne Robinson: They're
pretty much one thing for me.
I, teaching at Iowa, I just resigned
at the end of last semester,
high time I might say [laughter],
but in any case it was a
wonderful place for me.
It was absolutely ideal in the sense
that I would teach a
literature seminar and we all do,
you know one per semester and we
can teach absolutely anything.
So whatever was on
my mind was something
that I could organize a course
around, you know a lecture course
and it was phenomenally rich because
there's really no greater privilege
than talking about your
favorite literature
with these very gifted writers.
I mean that's excellent.
I had, I've been very
much influenced
by 19 century American literature.
I think that's clear and I
was often teaching Moby Dick
or Faulkner's novels or
something and they're very,
very full of religious illusion.
Moby Dick is just saturated with it.
So I started really,
seriously reading theology.
Reading specifically what Melville
would have been familiar with,
which is Calvin, you know?
And, so that the theological and the
literary were very much intertwined.
I think somebody writing in the 19
century would have sat through hours
and hours and hours
of theology in church.
And we basically, too many times
get sort of a minor uplift.
Something that uses a
little sports language,
a little advertising
language, you know?
[Laughter] And so I have to read
theology in order to know where,
you know Melville's mind would've
been or [inaudible] for that matter.
And so basically I, you know
these things were all one thing
in that sense.
>> Marie Arana: You have
said in your book because,
of course Marilynne besides
writing these extraordinary,
gem like novels, also writes,
publishes books of essays.
Her most recent one is the
Givenness of Things and what you say
in the Givenness of
Things that struck me is
that you think we have
gotten to the point
where there is precious
little joy in our lives.
How did you put, the
spirit of the times is one
of joyless urgency, you say.
And that we're all sort
of, I'm struggling for the,
the great God [inaudible]
or something and we're,
we've forgotten was, we
lost our way in a sense.
>> Marilynne Robinson: I think
we are distracted from joy.
I think that we're, we live in this
continuous conversation that implies
that everything has to be re-geared
and everybody should really be
studying, you know computer science
and you know what I mean?
And everybody is going to be
unemployed and you're going to have
to make yourself ingratiating and
useful to any theoretical employer
and all that sort of thing.
You know it's a terrible thing for
kids to think that they have to,
you know instead of thinking I
love [inaudible] or something,
they're thinking how am I ever
going to pay off my loans?
Who is going to hire me?
You know? This is a huge
step down from the way
that I was educated, for example.
I mean I was educated in the
old days before feminism.
I was educated generously
and elaborately
and I don't think anybody
had any notion
that anything would ever
come of it, you know?
[ Laughter ]
And you know, I mean
it's always have,
you know the glass is half full and
so on, but it was a great privilege
to be educated simply
in order to be educated.
I think that's one of the best
things you can experience in life.
>> Marie Arana: You have, speaking
of education, you have contact with,
with people who are not
particularly educated.
You, last night at the Author's
Festival Celebratory Gala,
which was a bit of a pep
talk before we all came
out to the Festival today,
you said that you had worked
with incarcerated people and, and
you had a chance to talk to them.
And one, one quote really
struck me in speaking to a man,
I wasn't sure he had, you had given
him the book, but he had read a book
and he had said something
about the fact that --
I didn't think the
world would interest me
as much as this or something --
>> Marilynne Robinson: Yeah.
>> Marie Arana: Like --
>> Marilynne Robinson: Found out the
world would be interesting to him
>> Marie Arana: Yeah.
>> Marilynne Robinson: Well you know
these are, in Iowa it's not uncommon
for writers to be invited to come
into prisons and talk with people
who have read their books, you know.
I mean they're in a reading group,
you know bless their hearts.
And the, so I've never had any
formal relationship with this,
it's just when I'm invited I come.
I find the people in prisons are
extraordinarily good readers,
you know?
They have not nearly enough
distraction to keep them, you know?
They really, they love books.
Books are intensely important
to them and so it's wonderful
from a writer's point of
view simply to talk to people
for whom they have
such meaning, you know?
I was very, Branell College
actually gives classes,
this is all donated time on the
part of the professors there,
they give classes at a rate that
end in a degree from Branell.
And the, you know a fair number of
inmates actually pass through this
and leave prison with
a college degree.
I mean, and a good
college, you know?
Well they're all good.
I don't want to, but [laughter].
In any case it's a kind
of a part of the culture,
I think that I have been drawn in
on and very, feel very privileged
to have been drawn in on.
I, as it happens the man that
I quoted was a cab driver I,
who drove me home from the
airport in upstate New York
who had spent 11 years in Attica,
I mean he spent years in Attica,
but 11 years in prison all
together and the other was a little,
God bless her, woman in Pocatello
Idaho in the women's prison there,
but you know the urgency which, with
which they are touched by books.
It's uncanny, it's
magic, it's beautiful
and I do always tell my students,
you know to write a book,
write your books for
the woman in Pocatello,
you know give her that good book.
They take it very seriously,
bless their hearts.
>> Marie Arana: You know, there is,
the remarkable thing, of course,
is that a book is an object
of, static object that sits
on your shelf and, until you
read it, until you engage in it,
and then the, all the work that the
writer does in a solitary fashion,
is done by you as a reader
in a solitary fashion.
And it's very rare, I think
that we have the chance
to actually hear beyond the
covers of that book, the feelings
and aspirations and, and
concerns of a writer.
So it's really wonderful to have
Marilynne present here today
to have her receive this
marvelous honor, which the Library
of Congress conveys and the Poetry
and Literature Center
is very much a part
of the Library of Congress conveys.
And it is, you know human, in fact I
wrote this down because I felt so --
Sort of, a little bit awestruck
by the way we were going to have
to communicate something
about so, such beautiful books
in human language like this,
you know which is so imperfect
and it reminded me of something
that Flaubert said in Madame Bovary
and he said something that,
here it is; human speech is
like a cracked kettle on which we
tap crude rhythms for bears to dance
to while we long to make
music that melts the stars.
Well Marilynne Robinson you
make music that melts the stars.
Thank you very much.
[ Applause ]
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.